DEFENSIVE ZONE TIME
OF BENN, AND THE
CAPTAIN ICES IT.
>> Andy: CHARLIE
COYLSHOT, SAVE BY
HOLTBY!
CAN'T CONTROL THE IT,
PAVELSKI DOES.
PASTRNAK THROUGH PLAYER
TECHNIQUE WITH HIS
STICK. IT.
HAULA CAN'T TAKE IT
AWAY, BUT JAKE
DEBRUSFROM
UP GETTING SOME IN, AND
GLENDENING WINS
ANOTHER ONE.
E TO GET
BACK WAY
OUT ON A
CLEAR MINUTE AND
NINE SECONDS.
COYLE A
STICK.
SMITH CAN'T
HAVE GONE OFF THE
GLASS AND Jack:  HAS A
SHORTHANDED
BREAKAWAY!
GLENDENING, OF THE CRIT
BOSTON IS JUST TRYING
TO COLLECT THAT PUCK Mc
HOLTTHE SAVE BY
SWAYMAN!
>> Andy: WELL,
CHARLIE OUT OF THE
CORNER.
SEKERA'S SHOT, JAKE
GUYS?
>> TAYLOR HALL,
IMIMTHE LINE MAN'S
LEGS.
HINTZ, TWIRLS IT
TOWARDS S
HOW CLOSE I CAME PLAY T
THE THE
CORNER.
HEISKANEN
INTERCEPTED, MARCHAND
LOFTS IT TO BERGERON.
LINDELL INTERCEPTS
PETERSON'S CENTERING
NET!
HE SCORES, AND THAT  OF